Take it.
Your head will explode.
So he's only got a little bit left.
How much time do you
think Charlie has left?
Oh man,
this can't last long.
He's,
he's throwing napalm on that candle.
He's not burning at both ends.
Well,
I think it's almost like he,
he's sick.
Like he's dying and he knows it and
so he decided to go out with a bang.
Well,
you know,
doctor,
you mysterious terminal illness.
It's called,
I like coke illness,
but maybe that's what he's doing.
I don't know.
I mean,
yeah,
he's a pretty fucked up.
It's cold.
There's girls are talking
about him doing it,
have briefcases of coke delivered.
That's not some shit.
You just get over hanging out by the pool,
you know,
Drinking Margarita.
So he's still getting drunk all the time.
He drinks his drinks,
whiskey or vodka on his show on that show.
He's got like a bottle with him.
He was trying to hide it.
Yeah.
It's,
you're not paying,
they're not paying you enough,
Charlie.
Shane,
you should hang it.
Or $1 million per show.
It's weird how other
people reacting to them.
Like Roger Ebert got Pissy with them.
Did you see that?
No one actually ever in Charlie's.
She ain't got in a Twitter
war and it was like,
I wish I,
you know,
I could live like Charlie Sheen,
but then my wife would leave me and I
don't want to be alone and miserable like
him.
I'm like,
whoa.
The claws come out,
Roger Ebert to loan.
You've got all this.
Why is Roger Ebert even talking like that
about Charlie Sheen that I could live
like that.
First of all,
dude,
no you couldn't.
You can't even talk.
He doesn't have a tongue anymore.
Right,
right.
Roger Ebert,
Hud's mouth cancers.
John isn't working where you
would think that would be the,
the least of his worries would
be what Charlie Sheen is doing.
You know?
That's so bizarre.
That would even comment on that.
And then Charlie Sheen responded
back and was something about,
you know,
you've never had five
girls at a time winning,
winning,
earn it.
Five girls at a time plan better.
That's not 11 is it?
No,
it's not like a lot.
Mostly
he must be like really lazy because if
you are having sex with that many people
you just kind of stay still
and let it like come around.
A friend of mine told me about when
he first started making money and uh,
he's a famous gentleman so I can't say
his name but he got two hookers at the
same time and he laid in
bed and just see her man.
Oops.
I almost did his voice.
He's like,
you haven't lived until you've had all
these women like tongs just licking your
body.
I think it was,
yeah,
it's was like it's impossible to not
freak out like it was like too much.
I was getting too much stimulation.
Wow.
I've had two and it was kind
of interesting but it was
more like you were at the
top.
I worked the bottom type thing.
I could imagine like the middle
part also that seems awesome.
Male feminists
give funny is that idea male feminists
and you're going to defend that nonsense
person.
You could just kidding.
It makes me angry.
Joe Rogan experience
podcast is how we do it.
This is backstage flowering.
Yes.
This is the dog,
the pts,
Brian Dog.
She's the sweetest,
most affectionate little
dogs probably ever existed.
She needs affection every second
of every minute of every hour.
Is that normal for dogs
that have this cow spots?
Yeah,
totally.
Are you a part cow?
Where's your belly button?
Right there.
I also,
I say fascinating
podcasts with young Andy.
Dick is the first time Andy and I have
seen each other in a couple of years,
years.
That was a lot of fun and
we got a lot out of the way.
A lot of talking about the old days.
A lot of bizarre shit.
Last sexual tension.
Yeah,
a lot of weirdness.
We talked about pretty much everything.
I'm having a little
sexual tension with Hubby.
The other thing I didn't
tell you about why I,
I'm sober again.
I got real sick like I
thought I was going to die.
I got to a place where like I'd
rather be dead at this point.
I feel that they was just from drinking.
My immune system went away and I got like
pneumonia and at my age at 45 you can,
you can die from.
That's how Rick James died.
That's how ammonia,
yeah,
so did Geraldo.
Greg,
Geraldo,
well,
your immune system goes down.
He went into a coma,
then he got pneumonia and die.
Really pneumonia is because
a lot of fucking people,
people get aids.
It's an acquired immune
deficiency syndrome.
It's your immune system goes away
and they usually die from pneumonia.
They don't,
you don't,
you're not dying from AIDS.
You get aids and then
you die from the mode.
And I'm just telling you I'm not,
I don't plan on drinking again.
Well you say quite a while,
you leave the door open though.
You know you were,
you,
you're leaving the door open.
See,
this is what I just don't
want to lie to myself.
I understand.
You know what I mean?
You don't have to,
you can promise yourself
and then keep a promise.
But you know,
this is the thing,
like when,
when people talk,
how about like you want to show with you,
you know,
and you say stuff like that.
They worry about Charlie,
she was sober for a long time.
What are you making?
2 million a week and it just fucking
keeps coming in and you've got to stop
pulling off and you've got a lot of balls
because everybody's kissing your ass
cause you come to the set
and they all rely on you.
You're the fucking rock star from Mars.
And now the next thing,
but if I'm doing a show with you,
no way he's going to be kissing,
but let us be screaming at me every day.
No,
you're right.
You're going to get an a go grad.
Have more
fucking dog
out to show you the super sophisticated
death squad podcast studios.
This is podcast studio number.
Yeah,
to podcasts.
Podcast to
Brian offers you to touch this.
The closest one.
Don't do it.
This is the one he's
been fucking for years.
It's covered in dirt and
dog hair and cat litter.
This is the studio.
This is where it all goes down.
This is the computer that Brian Works at.
Home Monitor set up.
And this is where Andy Dick Sat.
If you want to snip the seat,
this is what their satellite,
this is our satellite studio.
So when we're not doing it,
yeah,
my place to do it right here.
We're here with Al Magical of course,
Alan Opera partaking in this.
This is a,
this is a funny cigarette.
Uh,
that's all it is.
Preparation for the show you
to fire up the synapsis out.
Magical.
You fired up for the show too.
I am just excited.
It's going to be,
it's already packed inside and uh,
it's incredible when you get to go out
in front of Joe's audience because it's
real comedy fans and uh,
it's exciting.
You got a gun.
We almost lost everything their folks.
Uh,
it fell but only a small camera light.
Is that what it is that
you're sitting here?
It's like 10 to 10 buck on stage.
I'll mash bills onstage right now.
This is the world famous
comedy and Magic Club,
the most of the beach,
California.
So one of the most historic
comedy clubs in the country.
There's this writing on this
wall from 1978 and look at that.
That's like the earliest,
I think people have found a 78.
This is like a real classic,
Classic Comedy Club.
Jay Leno comes here every Sunday
and works is monologues ash.
And we're just sitting here freaking
out at about how crazy it is that,
uh,
we've done almost a
hundred fucking podcast.
It's pretty bizarre.
Doesn't it mean,
is that crazy?
Yeah,
that's a lot of,
if you think about that's
times two hours mostly.
Yeah.
How many hours?
I think what we try to do
on the podcast is we all,
we're all trying to have fun.
You know,
we're all hanging out together.
We're all talking about cool
and interesting shit and
we're trying to have fun.
And I think that's what a lot of fucking
people are missing in their life.
They're missing fun and they're
missing cool people to hang out with.
You know,
where everybody is enjoying
each other's company,
you know,
that's,
uh,
that's not present in everybody's life.
And with the podcast it's sorta
allows them to be on it there,
you know,
they can hang out and have these
cool two hour conversations with us.
They can't talk back,
but they can be there for
like a real conversation.
Not just wow,
just a show.
But really how you'd think about things.
Really.
How I think about things.
It's not,
you know,
sometimes it's weird like
when me and Pete Johansen,
you know,
we don't agree at all and sometimes
it's weird like Andy Dick,
he's trying to fuck me or you know,
sometimes it's weird where like when
we're talking to Adana Delmont Dana,
Dana Hermanns stories,
strangest fuck man.
She seems like this
really cool normal check,
you know?
And she's this crazy porn star,
but she's like really funny too.
It's a,
it's a fascinating gig.
You know,
I'm so glad that we started doing this.
we've been doing it over a year now,
just over a year.
And um,
it just started off as a goof,
right?
Remember?
Yeah,
we did.
You know,
the idea I think was when I,
we were always trying to
do the Justin TV thing.
I like doing like a weekly video,
like live from the green while
we're on the road and stuff.
And then we've,
I was always trying to like
push for that video thing.
So I think it started off when we've,
we didn't even think podcasts at first.
We were thinking of doing like a,
like a video show once a
week and Kumina inspired me.
Yeah.
Does that live at the compound?
There's so many fun guys that are smart.
I know when you get guys like
Dunkin and Brian Cowen and Eddie,
aft and Ari,
and there's so many dudes that would
have interesting opinions on so many
different subjects.
I sent the luckiest thing about the
podcast is that we get to have regular
conversations with all
these cool motherfuckers.
Man,
hasn't it made,
isn't it?
Do you think he's just improved your life?
How has it improved your life?
The podcast?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
It's an improved way you think?
Yeah,
because it's finally getting like putting
my thoughts and ideas to an audience,
so I absolutely,
yeah.
I mean that's what I've been trying to do,
you know,
at least on the Internet for a long
ass time and now it's finally coming
together.
Hey,
what's up?
What's the best thing?
The best thing we've ever done?
It's the best thing I've for sure because
it's the only thing I've ever done to
where it's really 100% mate.
You know?
You kind of like get to know who the fuck
somebody is when you watched them in a
standup routine or when you
see them act or you know,
maybe when you see him do some interviews,
but interviews are fucking quick,
man.
They're overbuilt.
You don't even know what the
fuck you were supposed to say.
It feel weird when you
leave like every time zone,
like a tonight show interview
or one of those things,
man,
you sit down in the chair
next to Jay went out.
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
I'm just trying to be funny.
I only have like seven minutes and
I'm just trying to keep it together.
Hey,
hey,
Nate are
anyway.
But with the podcast,
when you're,
when you're on for like two hours,
man,
you know,
you really get a chance
to talk to somebody.
You know exactly what though?
Like now people understand
the brilliance of Dunkin.
You know,
Dunkin is really good dude.
He's a fascinating motherfucker.
You know,
but it's really gets illustrated
on the podcasts and Brian Cowen,
there's a lot of people who
have no idea how smart Brian is.
What?
No idea of funny Joey fucking Diaz.
Yep.
That's what I think is the
best thing because like,
like,
like what you're talking about like,
and with the death squad,
I get to put a fucking these people out
of nowhere that no one would ever know
about,
at least to an audiences.
That's a
brilliant idea.
You,
you've created a radio station
in desk qualms radio station.
We're going to use this
as a video commercial.
It's brilliant idea.
And Brian Red band,
he's a fucking genius.
A mastermind.
He saw a head he saw into the future,
created a con damn broad band,
Internet radio network
type thing of podcasts.
You can't fuck with that.
You can't fuck one time.
Let me try to fuck with that.
I can't fuck with it.
You figured it out.
Crack the code.
He hack the system.
Top 20 on iTunes and what's up with that?
Talk to him to some
fucking dude from Columbus,
Ohio,
making people touch is dirty flashlight,
sick.
Fuck.
All right.
That's it.
Show's over.
That's a vagina.
Put your finger on it.
It's,
yeah,
it hasn't been washed.
One of my first gigs ever was
a little rider car show and,
uh,
they were going to have a bikini contest.
So to me,
and like three other comics and
the bikini girls don't show up.
So all these Latino dudes and oversized
white tee shirts with video cameras are
standing there waiting
for this bikini contest.
It never happens.
And they say,
well,
now instead of the Bikini contest,
we're gonna have the Comedians,
every moon walk away.
And then the crowd does for us to go.
And,
uh,
I look out in the middle of the
audience as I'm starting up,
and there's a little boy
holding his parents' hands,
uh,
just going like this,
looking at me,
flipping me off.
You just holding it,
not even moving.
He didn't flinch it off.
You just held it my entire sec.
I just looked at me and that's all
I could think about is this kid.
And so as I was doing,
I said,
it was like,
this is horrible.
So anytime I go up and I don't
see anybody paying attention,
you know,
we were talking about that's not into it.
Right.
I just think of that
little kid blew me off.
I was like,
yeah,
you're right.
Just having done that.
Okay.
[inaudible]
can we take pictures?
No,
no.
This is a perfect night.
Take a bunch.
Well,
I'll think about it.
Just keeps snapping them.
Number one right here.
It's going.
That's going.
Alright.
One more.
There it goes.
Good night.
Thank you.
Take care guys.
Right,
right.
Yeah.